had a billion dollars oh man whores no
um I actually don't need a billion
dollars so what I would do is like give
it away to charities and something I
would try to knock out like one problem
like I don't even know that's not enough
that's not enough to feed the world but
maybe like maybe like clothes for
everybody in the world I would buy
clothes so just knock that out so now
everyone has clothes that problem is
solved and then just to be a jerk about
it I would like tell everyone that I did
that like look what I just solved that
problem is non-existent anymore thanks
to me I'd be one of those assholes that
like tries to get a lot of publicity for
like doing good things like Richard
Branson